comme annoncé dans les titres maintenant
le château de versailles et de château
de versailles est visité par plus de 3
millions de personnes chaque année et en
restauration plus ou moins constant tout
de même en ce moment les travaux ont
pris de l'ampleur réfection des jardins
des fontaines notamment et de la célèbre
galerie des glaces imaginé par mansare
73 mètres de long en travaux jusqu'en
2007 pour autant l'endroit restera
accessible aux visiteurs ce chantier a
été entièrement financé faut savoir par
un mécène privé en l'occurrence groupe
vinci isabelle bechler anne laure
le commando anti poussière de la galerie
des glaces est exclusivement féminin en
ce premier jour de travaux sur la voûte
les aspirateurs des restauratrices
s'attaque à 50 ans de particules
accumulés dans les sculptures depuis la
dernière campagne de travaux des années
en répondant sans qu'il y ait beaucoup
de poussière au met imam
prenant place mais aussi la poussière il
va pas très important
trois cent vingt ans après la
réalisation de ce plafond par charles le
brun même les pinceaux de ces dames
doivent prendre des précautions notre
poule et soulèvement est parti vous
voyez vous ces partis qui risque de
soulever et pendant le dépoussiérage
pour éviter d'y toucher pour éviter de
faire partir des écailles c'est un
ouvrage complexe que cette voûte où se
combinent sculpture dorures stuc toile
les fresques le tout dans le plus beau
trompe-l'oeil france ait connu un trompe
l'oeil à l'italienne
avant tout faux dévots serré parce que
je sais pas si vous pouvez voir à
l'image la quantité des poussières
qu'elle est déposée sous la surface et
celui-ci sa surface verticale mais sous
la corniche il ya des amas très
important voici comment le brand a
relaté les vingt premières années du
règne de louis xiv voici ce que viennent
voir 3 millions de visiteurs chaque
année il était urgent qu'il ne soit pas
trop frustré par l'échafaudage et la
restauration on a donc gardé visible un
tiers de la galerie des glaces tout en
tentant de recréer la perspective et la
magie du lieu
le tout étant que les visiteurs ne soit
pas gênée d'avoir des restaurateurs au
dessus de leur tête
un
petit peu déçue sort était magnifique de
voir la galerie des glaces en entier
mais soit on envoie est déjà assez
fabuleux est à couper le souffle le
château et aux royalistes on a vraiment
rien de tel aux états unis par kent
state
en trois années de restauration de ce
lieu historique c'est quand même là que
le traité de versailles a mis un point
d'orgue à la première guerre mondiale 9
millions de visiteurs vont emprunter ce
tunnel de miroirs qui permet la
restauration de la voûte presque à leur
insu